>> Elizabeth Blair: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Elizabeth
Blair: Megan Abbott as most
of you probably know, is the queen
of noir, the queen of crime fiction.
She's an Edgar-winning author of
seven novels, including The End
of Everything, The Fever and,
most recently, You Will Know Me.
Her stories have appeared
in multiple collections including
Best American Mystery Stores
of 2014 and 2016.
She's from the Detroit Area.
She graduated from the university of
Michigan and got her PhD in English
and American literature from NYU.
And was the John Grisham writer
and resident of Ole Miss.
But better than all of that,
Megan Abbott writes about girls
and women we probably
all feel like we know,
and puts them in some
pretty harrowing situations.
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Please
welcome Megan Abbott.
[ Applause ]
>> Megan Abbott: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I feel a little bit like Norma
Desmond with these lights.
It's very dramatic.
>> Elizabeth Blair: I know.
You can't really see their faces.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: You don't know
what expressions they might have
on them.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: But definitely I
would love to start with just women,
girls, teenage girls, moms.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: This is a
world you seem to really love.
And I have my own reasons why that
might be, but please tell us why.
Why do you want women at
the center of your novels?
>> Megan Abbott: I guess, you
know, it just sort of happened.
It's so interesting that it's sort
of specific to write about women.
If you have crime novels and you
write about men, no one says,
"Why do you write about men?"
But it is weird because
historically in America at least,
crime fiction has this
reputation for being
about men, about the world of men.
Or these traditional
male areas of you know,
the police and private detectives.
And so I was more interested in
the sort of mystery of women.
Especially because it seemed to
me -- to start with teenage girls,
there were sort of awful stereotypes
that were perpetuated in fiction
and in society of teenage
girls as vapid, as superficial,
as sort of the selfie-taking morons.
And it was so offensive to me.
And I just thought there was, you
know, so much more interesting stuff
to say about girls, particularly the
things we're not supposed to feel.
Like aggression or
ambition or desire.
And so that was sort of
how I found my way in.
And that became a way to explore
all kinds of female relationships.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Well having
been a teenage girl once,
I can tell you it is
like fertile ground.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: When I'm reading
your books I'm always thinking,
"I know that girl.
That girl was -- " well I won't say
her name, but Megan knows her also.
>> Megan Abbott: That's right.
We all know those girls.
>> Elizabeth Blair: That's right.
And I interviewed you
when The Fever came out.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: And I
remember you said you quoted Freud
as saying something like, "We're
all arrested at a certain age,
and I'm arrested around 14 or 15."
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: So
I didn't ask you then,
but I'm going to ask you now
in front of all these people,
what were you like as a teenager?
>> Megan Abbott: Oh boy.
That's a great question.
I suppose I was bookish, you know.
I certainly was.
But I do remember I
grew up in the Midwest,
sort of really All-American
girl land
where these expectations
-- this was in the '80's.
So there really was
an idea of girlhood
that was very dominant in that era.
The era of the John
Hughes movies, you know,
which were actually welcome
relief compared to sort
of the more stereotypical
version of teenage girls.
But I was sort of insatiably
curious and fascinated
by I suppose what we would
now say are dark things.
I liked creepy books.
I like true crime.
I like to have adventures.
You know, which I think
is most girls at that age.
You want out.
You want out in the world.
You're not quite ready
for it, but you want it.
Which makes it sort of a terrifying
moment once you're an adult
and you have kids of your own.
But at that age it feels
exactly the right thing.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
Teenage girl relationships are
really important in your novels.
How would you describe those
relationships when you were
in high school between girls?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
Occasionally, what they would
now call toxic I suppose.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Right.
>> Megan Abbott: You know, all of
you who are women in the room know,
and I'm sure most of the men
know from the women they know,
that there can be very volatile
friendships at that age.
In some ways they're
rehearsals for romances to come,
for what you don't want in a
relationship as an adult, you know?
So you're kind of figuring
out what the boundaries are
and what's acceptable.
And there's a lot of passion to
it that can be heartbreaking.
So many women I know who've read
one of my books and talked about it,
their first heartbreak was
really from a friendship,
not from a romantic relationship.
But the friendships
are somewhat romantic.
So that just seems obviously for a
crime novel, that's ripe terrain.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
And that's very much
the case in The Fever.
But I would love to talk
about your last book.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair:
You Will Know Me.
And I would love for you to read
the first page, if you don't mind.
>> Megan Abbott: Sure.
Sure, yes.
This is from the point
of view of Katie.
So Katie is the mother of a
gymnast, and this is her --
I'm not going to say any more
because it's the first page.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Okay.
>> Megan Abbott: If she
ever had to talk about it,
which she never would,
Katie would have to go back.
Back years before it happened,
before Coach T and Haley
and Ryan Beck, back
before Devin was born.
When there were only two Knoxes,
neither of whom knew a Tuck
from a Salto or what you called
that glossy egg-shaped platform
in the center of the room, the
vault that would change their lives.
And Katie would tell the
story in three parts:
the foot, the fall, the pit.
You could only begin to
understand what happened and why
if you understood those
three things.
And Devin's talent, because that
had been there from the beginning.
Maybe even before the beginning.
In proud parent moments in which
there were too many to count,
she and Eric would talk about
feeling Devin in the womb,
her body arching and minnowing
and promising itself to them both.
>> Elizabeth Blair: How
important is that first page?
>> Megan Abbott: So much.
It's the part that gets written,
rewritten the most times.
And sort of you know, in this case
weirdly the first line remained
the same.
But most everything else
I just read changed.
Even that foot, fall, pit thing
which becomes the structural device
for the first part of
the book came later.
You know, the first page is really
when most readers decide
a lot of things.
We all know it.
I do it too.
Sometimes it's because
you're in the bookstore
and you're looking
at the first page.
Sometimes you get the sample on
your E-reader or whatever it is.
You need to be grabbed.
So I always wanted
to feel very intimate
and sort of like a confessional.
So trying to sort of reach out
to the reader and you know,
"I need to tell you this thing."
You know. And that's always what
I'm going for in the first page.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Well it's
funny about the first page,
about sort of confessing.
Yes, I go to the bookstore
and if you don't have me
at that first page, I'm probably
not going to buy that book.
But I have a 12-year-old son and
the teachers tell the kids now,
read the first few pages.
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
>> Elizabeth Blair: I mean,
I think they're not saying,
"If you don't like it, put it down."
They're saying, "If it's just
right for your reading level,
then this is something
you should buy."
>> Megan Abbott: Right.
>> Elizabeth Blair: But I think
in any form of entertainment,
the first few notes of a song,
the first words of a book,
the first scene in a
movie are so important.
And I was wondering
if it's something
that takes longer than
everything else.
>> Megan Abbott: It is.
I mean, you know it when
you're writing and you have it.
Or you think you do.
You think you have something
that is arresting in some way,
and it is a lot like the culture
of oversaturation, you know?
And peak TV and podcasts
and all these things.
And I think we make a lot
of decisions all the time
about what we're going
to continue with.
So you know, you want to
connect and you want it
to feel personal or intimate.
And with a crime novel, obviously
you want to suggest in some way
that something's going to happen.
Which is what separates
us from some other genres.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Right.
Right, right.
>> Megan Abbott: So I love them all.
>> Elizabeth Blair:
For You Will Know Me,
where did the story idea come from,
the idea to focus on gymnasts?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
It was a slow process.
I was really interested in
prodigy families and I had read
that wonderful Andrew Solomon book
from a few years ago called Far
From the Tree, which is a
nonfiction book about the parents
of different kinds of
exceptional children.
But prodigies, some
had a disability.
Some had come into decline.
There's this range of experiences.
But how the families sort of dealt
with the child's issue or concern
or special talent,
and how power operated
in the family was really
interesting.
And then I landed on gymnastics
because I was watching
the 2012 Olympics.
And I will never forget it.
It was the London one
and the gymnastics team
was fabulous of course.
And Allie Reisman who was
also on the 2016 team,
her parents were watching
her perform
and there was this
famous viral footage.
And they did this again in 2016
where they were watching her do her
bar routine and they were both going
like this as her body would turn.
And they would go like this,
and then they would go, "Oh!"
And then at the end when she
sort of nailed it, they stood up
and did this fist pump,
this Boston proud family.
And I became so interested in
that kind of marriage, you know,
when both parents are so invested.
And that's how I sort of found
Katie and Eric in the book.
I wanted to sort of explore
what that would be like.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
Well in many ways this book is
a lot about moms and parents
and how they deal with each
other and then they deal
with the community that they're in.
And the ambitions of this
community and individuals.
And it's kind of scary because
it does mirror some reality,
because you think, "Yes, I've been
to that soccer game with the moms
who are far too invested, and dads."
But I am wondering, for you,
the gymnastics world
-- were you a gymnast?
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah, I have
no athletic capacity at all.
And it comes out in a
lot of books I write.
I've written about cheerleaders.
I had a hockey player in The Fever.
And I think this is my
other Freudian revelation,
is that clearly I want
to be an athlete.
And I'm working it out.
A 14-year-old Megan says, "Why can't
I be good at any of these sports?"
So when you're short and you
can't even do gymnastics -- so no.
I think for me, anybody who sort
of has mastery of their body
in some way fascinated me.
But gymnastics in particular
has this function
where they start training
so early, serious gymnasts,
that it actually can sort
of stall their development.
Puberty can be delayed.
And that seemed fascinating
to me for a number of reasons.
But not the least of which,
what it's like as a parent
to somehow be involved in something
that stops your daughter
from coming of age.
You know, she doesn't
get her period.
Most gymnasts don't
get their period --
sorry for talking about
periods on a Saturday afternoon.
But they don't hit their periods
till their 20's, you know?
Like everything is stopped and
their body develops differently
to accommodate it.
And they don't want to get breasts
because it will affect
the physics of gymnastics.
So that just like for a writer,
of course that's so exciting.
For a person it's tragic.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
>> Elizabeth Blair:
And why crime fiction?
Why do you think you are so
drawn to writing crime novels?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah,
I think of that a lot.
I mean, you know, some crime
writers are very much interested
in the procedural elements,
which I am as a reader,
but not as a reader
but not as a writer.
Because my mind doesn't work.
My books don't have
like a series of clues.
I mean, there are clues sort of,
but it's not like the Agatha
Christie you know, or Nancy Drew
or any of the sort of classic ones.
But I do like sort
of people in crisis,
how they handle it
and how they respond.
And people kind of reckoning
with their own darkness,
or the darkness of those they love.
That just endlessly fascinates me.
So I was really the kid who --
and so many crime novelists I
know have had the same experience.
But you know, you'd be in the
used book store and you're
like ten years old and
there's Helter-Skelter
and you open the new one and look
at the pictures, which is grotesque.
But you do.
There's a curiosity that you have
to get comfortable with it yourself.
And also know what
its limits are too.
So it doesn't become
indulgent or sensational.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
And then with your process, do
you come up with the crime first
and then build the world and
the characters around it?
Or what's your --
>> Megan Abbott: It's usually the
character first and situation.
Sometimes I have a crime and then
I'm trying to find the character.
I'm trying to matchmake, and it
doesn't -- that's a little harder.
Almost always it's have a
character and then I'm sort
of searching for a crime.
And it's also a real-life
case, like The Fever
or in this case it wasn't a crime,
but a real-life inspiration.
But I start with character.
If I can't nail the
voice of the character,
then it's the wrong story.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
>> Megan Abbott: So
that has to be --
you know, I've had
many false starts.
You know, every book
there's been two
or three false starts
before I find the one.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
I don't know how many
people know about The Fever,
that it really was
drawn from a true story.
If you want to talk
about that a little bit.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes, yes.
Some of you may remember it, but
there was this famous case --
I think it was about
five years ago now.
In upstate New York
these young girls,
all of them developed these
ticks, these motor ticks.
And it sort of spread through the
school in this very small town.
And it became sort of a phenomenon.
And Aaron Brockavic arrived.
They thought maybe
it was environmental.
Other people thought there
was some kind of Lyme disease.
There were all these
theories about it.
And in the end it was
primarily diagnosed
as this psychogenic illness,
this kind of hysteria.
So the symptoms were real, but it
came from a psychological place.
So that just -- I mean
that just felt
like it was right in my wheelhouse.
It was calling to me,
"Write about me."
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
I mean, maybe it was planned,
because it was a Megan Abbott
novel in the making for sure.
For sure. Tell me a little bit more
about your process and your day.
When do you write?
What's the best time of
day for you to write?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
I have to sort of block out the day.
So I tend to be most productive in
the morning, but I don't just sit
down and do my two hours.
I'm not fast enough or
organized, a thinker enough.
So I just basically write on and
off all day in these sort of spurts
between you know, the distraction.
I mean now, the last eight
months or so there have been
so many distractions with the world.
You know, I talked to so
many writers across genre
that the distraction
of the news has been --
and sort of the need to follow
the news has made it harder.
But I do try to block that out.
And I have these spurts.
In the last few years
I've done some TV writing.
And that's a different motor.
Like I can turn that on
at any time and plug in.
It's much faster, because
it's not as interior.
So I'm really aware of how important
the novel writing process is for me,
that I don't sort of just plug in.
That I really like try to sit in
that world, imagine the characters
and just sort of --
it's sort of like going
into cold water stage
by stage by stage.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
I heard you say once that you
can't sort of have lunch and sort
of pull yourself away
from the atmosphere,
because then you're
completely derailed.
>> Megan Abbott: It's true.
People get annoyed and they
think I'm being suppressive.
Like, "Let's have lunch."
And I say, "Can we
have dinner instead?"
You know, because if we have
lunch, then I will sit at lunch
and I will probably order a beer,
something I never would normally do,
because I know I don't
have to go back to work now
and I have the rest of the day off.
I can't get in that head again,
because I'm in this
social head, you know?
And it's impossible to get back in.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
Are there real stories going
on in the world right now
that you're watching and
thinking, "That's my next novel"?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
I have a few on my ticker now.
I'm sort of following them.
People now send me them all
the time, which is great.
There was -- I shouldn't
even say it,
because maybe I'll write about it.
But there was this great case last
year of these twin yoga teachers
and one of them killed the
other one on a Hawaiian cliff.
She drove the car off a cliff.
And then it turned out they had
this very weird relationship.
And it's fascinating.
And I think 30 or 40 people sent
me that article when it came out.
[Laughs]. "You've got
to write about this."
Or the teenage girl who
texted her boyfriend
and then he killed himself,
which is a terrible store.
And actually I wouldn't
write about that.
You know, you make these decisions.
That one felt very upsetting to
me and I didn't want to write it.
But a lot of people
sent me that too.
So in fact, another writer I know
actually emailed me yesterday
to say, "Are you going
to write about it?
Because I might."
That's a no-go.
[Laughs].
>> Elizabeth Blair: Just
don't make it a hit.
>> Megan Abbott: That's right.
And I wouldn't -- you know,
these decisions we make about --
because you live when
you write a novel.
It takes me a year and a half maybe
to write a novel, sometimes
a little more.
And so you're living in
this space for a while.
And there are certain spaces that
I just know I don't want to live
in for that long, you know.
It's too unpleasant.
I don't have any copilots that feel
right, like with You Will Know Me,
there were characters I liked.
And I knew I would be
comfortable with them.
I like Katie.
Once I figured out how I liked
her, I could go with her.
>> Elizabeth Blair:
Tell us about Katie.
>> Megan Abbott: Katie, she's -- I
was really resistant to doing kind
of a classic stage mom,
even though in some ways
from the outside she could
be viewed as a stage mom.
So I really wanted her to be someone
who had no plan for her daughter
to be anything but her daughter.
But her daughter had
this special talent.
And early on in the book --
very early so it's not a spoiler
-- but I won't go into it.
There's something that happens
to Devin when she's a little girl
that increases Katie's worry for
her and protectiveness of her.
And her wanting to make
everything right for her.
And so I think she really thinks
she's doing the right thing
by Devin.
In many ways she is.
But I think it also can be, when
you're in these communities,
these sports communities
or music communities
or whatever the special
talent is, can be really hard
to keep perspective because everyone
you know is also in that world.
And you have no barometer -- you
know, you have no way to measure it.
And I think that Katie does
get a little lost in that.
But I wanted it to feel that
she was coming from a good space
so that we would follow her there.
>> Elizabeth Blair: I
love when the mothers say
to her, "What's your secret?
You know, what are
you guys feeding her?
I'll feed my daughter so
she'll be just as successful.
Yeah, I do think there's
some of that that goes on.
The parents are thinking all they
have to do is tweak the appetite
or the schedule, and it's
really hard on kids I think.
>> Megan Abbott: I think so too.
>> Elizabeth Blair: The
parents' expectations can be very
debilitating for the kids.
>> Megan Abbott: Oh, so true.
You know, it's almost
like they're talking
about a horserace when they do that.
What's the diet?
You know, this is our show horse.
We're competing.
But there's another part of
it that a lot of prodigies
or just very talented
young athletes,
they do want it very badly.
And I think it's very
hard to tell them apart.
And sometimes they
want it very badly.
My brother was a very intense
baseball player as a kid.
And my parents were very involved.
And we went to all the Little League
games and I was the kid sitting
in the stands bored to tears because
the games would last forever.
And my parents were
really motivated.
And at a certain point he
lost interest, you know?
He was 14.
Other things started to
seem interesting to him.
But luckily he felt comfortable
saying it and they felt fine I think
with not surrendering
yourself to baseball anymore.
>> Elizabeth Blair: So you're Drew?
>> Megan Abbott: I'm Drew.
There's a little brother.
I am definitely Drew.
Yes. I was the bookish one.
My brother is really bookish too,
but he was a really good athlete
and I was never -- as stated,
I was never the athlete.
I wanted to be.
So I did see it from the outside
so I had a little more perspective.
The little brother in the book I
think is the only one in the family
who really kind of sees what's going
on, even though he's quite young.
>> Elizabeth Blair: I also
noticed that technology --
social media, which has so
revolutionized what it's
like to be a teenager right now.
You don't engage in that a lot.
And I'm wondering if as a
writer, if you grapple with that,
given that teenagers are
who you really like to --
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
I think about that a lot.
It's sort of I got a
free pass with this
because Devin doesn't really have
friendships because she's so --
she doesn't have many
peer relationships.
So that's not part
of her experience.
It's somewhat a part of The Fever.
But the book I wrote
before that, Dare Me,
which is about the
cheerleading squad --
if I wrote that now --
that came out in 2012.
There's some texting
and social media in it.
But if I wrote it now, I would have
to write it completely differently.
Because it's become you know
-- so when I wrote it was 2010.
So in the past eight years --
you know, every seven years --
it's become so much
a function of it.
But there is something deadly about
reading text messages in a novel.
You know? Because if your text
messages are anything like mine,
they are not very literary.
And they are filled
with emojis and things
that you know -- that's
not why we read.
On the other hand,
if used effectively I
think they can be a tool,
the way we're so attached
to our phone now.
And I'm addicted to my phone
as much as teenagers, right?
We all know it.
Your phone, you're so used to having
it in your hand or on your person,
you're always looking for it.
You feel those false vibrations
that they say some of us feel.
That can be useful in a crime novel
because of course it adds the sort
of nerve-wracking element, you know.
They've used it sometimes
in TV and movies too,
that jolt you know of the phone.
This phone is like a living thing.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Because I
know you talk to teenagers a lot
as part of your research, right?
Talk to gymnasts or
cheerleaders or whoever.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Do you sense
that you're understanding them
as much as -- did you want
to understand teenagers
since you were arrested in that age?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Or is it now
becoming a real cultural shift
for what they're like?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
Boy, that's a good question.
I think there's certain eternals.
There's certain things
I'm never going
to get, and I don't pretend to.
And sometimes I'll go on
say Tumblr or something.
Sometimes they'll be on Tumblr.
It's a big teenage girl space,
or at least was as of last week.
Because sometimes they'll
tag one of my books, right?
So I'll go there.
I don't even know what
I'm looking at, you know.
They do book trailers for your book.
You know, it's wild and these images
and there's this slang I don't know.
And so I really do try to keep up.
But there's a lot of stuff
that I do not have access to.
On the other hand, there are
so many eternals, you know.
The friendship element is the same.
That sense of being on the
precipice and seeking more.
That sense of -- I think for teenage
girls now you have all this power
and no power at all.
I think that's always there.
So I try to in the books stick
to those things and not rely
on the more ephemeral elements.
I've been developing my
novel Dare Me for TV.
And I've had to keep changing
all the cultural references
with each stage of development, you
know, because it goes on forever.
So you're rewriting the script.
Like I have to take this Rihanna
thing out because you know,
that is no longer a
teenage thing, you know?
I mean, for some teenagers.
But you know, the cultural
references just date immediately.
And in a book you really don't want
to do that if you can avoid it.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
So you are writing
for HBO's The Deuce.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
And that's really exciting.
I haven't seen it yet.
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah,
it premiers next weekend.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
But as I understand it,
another great crime novelist,
George Pelecanos, who I adore --
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
DC proud!
>> Elizabeth Blair: DC.
Go DC. In the house.
How did it come about?
>> Megan Abbott: David
Simon is fairly local.
Some of you may know The Wire.
And George Pelecanos
developed the project together.
It's called The Deuce.
It's set in 1970's Times Square.
And it's about the birth
of the porn industry
in Times Square at that moment.
And they were looking for crime
writers to add to the cast.
There's crime elements in
the show, but I don't know.
I think David Simon
and George Pelecanos --
well, George as a crime novelist --
they both tend to work
with crime novels.
Richard Price is also
in the writers room.
And Dennis Lehane of course
famously wrote on The Wire.
And so they like to
have crime writers.
And because of the
pornography subject,
I think they thought,
"We need some women."
[ Laughter ]
So I knew George pretty well
and I knew David a little bit
through his wife, the great
crime novelist Laura Litman.
So they asked if I
would be interested.
And of course it was like -- you
know, between David Simon, Pelecanos
and Price it was like the
holy trinity of crime fiction.
So there was no way I
was going to say no.
I would have done anything.
I would have done it for free if
the Writers Guild would let me.
Thankfully they didn't,
so I actually got paid.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Well we have
15 minutes left and we'd love
to hear some questions
from people out there.
>> Hi.
>> Megan Abbott: Hi.
>> As a huge sports fan,
a graduate of Notre Dame,
a fellow Midwesterner, as also a
parent of a daughter and two sons
who all play competitive sports,
I really want to thank you
for really ripping the scab
off of the predatory nature
of specialized sports and youth.
I think it's really
gone way too far.
I actually refuse to let any of
my kids do individualized sports,
because I said the only
value of sports is learning
to be a good team player.
And I was wondering if you
interviewed any gymnasts from Bella.
Specifically any of the members
of the 2008 gymnastics team.
Sports Illustrated did a huge
article and it was fascinating.
None of those women will let any
of their daughters do gymnastics.
They say no way.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your
question and your kind words.
This has been quite a
gymnastics scandal since the book.
But it was already there.
You know, a lot of
gymnasts, so sort of coaches
who were predating on gymnasts.
And it's sort of slowly
unfolded over a long time.
And it was somehow covered up,
as all these stories usually are.
And that was something
that came up a lot.
Not in the interviews I did,
but in the sort of exposes
that had been written,
and the memoirs.
A lot of former gymnasts
had written about it,
but nobody had really covered it.
And nobody saw it
as an institutional problem
or a systemic problem.
But I didn't interview any
of Bella's very famous
gymnastics coaches.
And famously abusive -- not
sexually, but a mean guy.
I didn't interview
any of his gymnasts.
So I did interview a gymnast
whose sister had trained with him.
And I interviewed some gymnasts
who had had very intense
training experiences
and had been homeschooled,
which a lot of them are.
And could really speak to a
lot of the weird body issues.
But also it was a good balance,
because a lot of them spoke
to how wonderful the sport was
for them and what it did for them
in making them feel powerful
and strong at a young age.
There are so many positives to it
that it makes it doubly a shame
when these other elements sort
of you know, take that away
from the kids doing it,
and from the parents
who are just enjoying
it and being supportive.
So like anything, it
has a dark side.
But gymnastics in particular
is a dark side.
It's really reared
its ugly head of late.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Yeah.
>> Hi. This is more
of a process question.
You were saying how if somebody
wants you to take a break,
that you can't get back into it.
But do you ever have times where
you're done writing for the day
but then an idea comes to you
and you're just like, "Oh,
I have to go back and
write this now"?
>> Megan Abbott: Yes, yes.
I do. Thankfully.
Those are the best moments.
You know, it's sort of
the news takes over.
Yes, it's often when I've
moved away from the computer.
The ideas immediately come.
You know, because I think we do
get stuck in our -- do you write?
If we stuck in our tunnels, and
I think it becomes very hard.
I'll take a walk and I'll be
walking and I will like figure
out the whole plot problem or like
what the character needs to say.
And often I'll do this.
I used to write it down
in a little notebook.
I still have the notebook
in my purse.
But now I'll actually
send an email to myself.
I'll like punch it out and.
And I have this weird
thing that happens.
Someone has an email address
exactly like mine, a Gmail address.
And there's only one
difference in our address.
And so occasionally she gets emails
that are supposed to be for me.
Occasionally she gets emails that
I think I'm emailing to myself.
[ Laughter ]
And sometimes they're really
violent and she gets it
because she knows I'm
a crime novelist now.
But at first she was really
frightened because it would be like,
"She should take the
knife right now."
So we have a good relationship.
>> Thank you.
>> Megan Abbott: She does crew and
occasionally I get emails about --
she actually lives in DC.
It would be great if
she were here today.
Megan?
>> Hi. So you were talking
earlier about how sick you were
about this sort of reductive mean
girls stereotype when it comes
to the writing of teenage girls.
How do you balance that so that
when you write them you're able
to make them sort of complex,
flawed people who make
questionable choices?
But people's take away isn't, "Wow,
teenage girls are really bitchy."
>> Megan Abbott: Right.
I mean, that's exactly it.
It's the tricky part.
I mean, I think part of
it is sort of like --
in crime fiction there's the
famous fem fatale character, right?
Who's the lethal lady.
And I was always interested
when I read classic crime
fiction what the book would be
like if it were written
from their point of view.
In which case everything
would be different, right?
And we would sympathize
with the fem fatale
and we would understand her motives
for making the guy kill her husband
or whatever she's making him do.
And I think it's a similar
thing with mean girls,
only they're much less lethal.
But I really do try to view
things from their point of view.
And I've always -- perhaps
this just speaks more
to my high school experience --
but it was always kind
of like a battlefield.
And the strong survive.
And there is a Lord of the
Flies element for a lot of us.
And you know, in some ways the
armor the mean girls wear is
because of the circumstance
they're in.
And girls can be really
hard on each other in ways
that are not obvious, you know.
And they're not socialized to
express certain feelings, you know.
Whereas boys may get in
a fistfight or something,
but it's not the way
girls are supposed to be.
So it becomes very complicated.
So I try to sort of put
all that into perspective.
And usually what happens -- so in
my book Dare Me I have what people
often call my classic mean girl,
looking at that trope
and looking at my books.
And her name is Beth.
And she's my favorite character.
And I grew to love her so
much by the end of the book,
even though I intended her to
be the antagonist in some way.
But I actually changed
the whole plot
so that she would have a more
sympathetic place in the story.
And I just grew to love her.
So I try to really like view
that as my role, is to love them.
>> Thank you.
>> Megan Abbott: Even though
other people hate her.
[ Laughter ]
>> I guess my question was
actually about Dare Me.
And this is kind of a spoiler
for the end of the book, but --
>> Megan Abbott: So
everyone close their ears
if they don't want a spoiler.
>> So I guess I was just
wondering what your thinking was
about the fact that Beth and
the main character had this
like sexual relationship?
And in what sense do you
think that formed the rift?
>> Megan Abbott: Yeah.
Yeah. That to me was always there.
And it was just a question
of like when to reveal it.
But I guess what we were
talking about before,
these intense female
friendships that often border
on romance and sometimes are.
And sometimes they're the space in
between and you don't really know.
In some ways one of the things I
love most about the millennials is
that all these sort of strict
divisions that my generation had
in terms of gay, straight,
male, female, very --
like we knew what we were.
But there was no space in between.
It's really kind of
in large part gone.
And I wanted the book to be
in that space where this --
it definitely explained a lot of
the intensity of their relationship,
but it didn't define them.
It wasn't meant to be this
is why this all happened.
It was meant to show how
truly emotionally involved
with one another they
were and how deep it went.
Does that make sense.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> So many of your early books
focused on this noir universe.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes.
>> And I'm curious if you
miss that universe at all.
And also how that shaped
the way that you write
about you know, current day.
>> Megan Abbott: Yes, yes.
My first four books are
all sort of historical,
more classic noir,
inspired by film noir.
And sort of viewing the fem
fatale from the inside was sort
of the way I approached those books.
And I really love -- I
started writing those books
because I loved the mid
last century, you know,
30's, 40's, 50's America.
And I do miss that.
That's mostly what I have
done short stories in.
It's sort of my outlet for it.
But I do hope to go
back to it someday.
I think the carryover
is that weirdly,
those noir novels are
at a very high pitch.
They're very baroque and big.
And it was very easy to go
into writing teenage girl
world from that world.
It felt like it was a perfect match.
I didn't have to step down at all.
And then it kind of
feels the same to me.
The thing I miss is getting
to talk about the clothes
and the nightclubs
and the race tracks.
That I miss.
You know, suburban life
is not as compelling.
So I try to give texture to that.
And that's kind of one way
how I know I'm into a book.
Like the gym world.
Once I've pounded out sort of
the visceral stuff to hang onto
and the details of it
and the body stuff,
and that sort of is a
substitution for the great clothes.
>> Elizabeth Blair:
Well now we've got HBO.
We've got the whole visual
porn industry I guess.
>> Megan Abbott: That's right.
That's right.
>> Hi, Megan.
I loved You Will Know Me.
>> Megan Abbott: Thank you.
>> Goodreads tells me you have
something coming out in 2018.
And I just wondered if
you can give us any sense
of what we have to look forward to.
>> Megan Abbott: Oh, thank you.
Yeah, I have a book coming out.
I think it's going to be next July.
It's called Give Me Your Hand.
And it's about two
female scientists.
I really became interested in
the role that women in science --
still so much the minority
in so many of the sciences.
So very much a male
universe still by and large.
And so this is about two female
scientists who share a secret.
And then lots of bad stuff happens.
So I guess I sort of wanted
to do something a little
more Hitchcockian.
So the lab is sort of
to me a fascinating
and creepy and beautiful space.
So that was sort of the
inspiration behind that.
And like for women working
in that world it becomes
a kind of sub-story.
>> Elizabeth Blair: I think we
only have a couple of minutes.
It goes fast.
But I do want to find out -- there's
a book that's always on your shelf
with the word psychic in the title.
>> Megan Abbott: Oh yes.
There is. How to Defend
Yourself Against Psychic Attacks.
>> Elizabeth Blair: This is the
book that's always on her shelf.
>> Megan Abbott: Which makes
me sound crazy in parting.
But a friend of mine,
another crime novelist,
Sarah Graham gave me that book.
Because we get very superstitious.
Writers in general I think are
very superstitious, like athletes.
And like good energy around a
book seemed really important.
And so she gave me this book
which is sort of to ward off --
and she also gave me a
voodoo sort of bag of charms
that her other friends
have given her.
I also do prayer candles.
It's crazy.
But it's not that I do or don't
believe in psychic attacks.
But having the book there,
everything's gone okay
in my personal life, at
least in my writing life.
It's gone okay.
so I'm keeping the book
there until things turn.
>> Elizabeth Blair: Well,
Megan Abbott, thank you.
Thank you very much.
>> Megan Abbott: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.